Good evening.
I hope all the things that we
had discussed so far are clear
on anything that we should spend
a couple of minutes on.
OK, then what we will do is that
we will go into an essentially a
new topic.
So.
So what we will do is that we
Start learning how to do a
modeling so that we generate the
first model from the data.
So essentially we will check how
to do machine learning so that
given some data we generate a
simple model which is a decision
tree.
So here are many examples and in
fact classification is one of
the one of the most popular.
In fact, not one of the IT is
the.
It is possibly the most popular.
Young married task that people
perform.
So there are because this as a
predictive nature.
This is representing a
predictive nature and that this
is essentially representing a
method of learning from data
instead of describing the data.
So for that reason, this happens
to be one of the very popular
task, or in fact the most
popular task that the data
scientists keep performing,
given some data, do they they
want to recognize certain
patterns whereby they can make
predictions about something that
they have not seen.
So a simple example can be that.
So a doctor has been diagnosing
for a disease based on the X
ray.
So what the person is diagnosing
somethings which are which can
be diagnosed with the help of X
ray or it can be other than
other other things like cats can
or or any any other mechanism
which is creating a report.
So what the machine learning?
How how does the machine
learning help them?
So what their doctors have to do
is that they need to.
They would have diagnosed
possibly thousands of patients.
They need to create a training
data so the training data shows
the xrays which indicate that
the disease is present and the X
rays that indicate that the
disease is not present.
So once this training is done on
the machine, so after the
training is done, if a new X ray
is given for whom the diagnosis
or the conclusion is not drawn,
the machine will be able to
conclude whether the person has
disease or so.
That is an example.
So the reason why I gave the
example is that this is this is
a classification, is a task that
is very popular in many, many
domains for solving ohh various
business problems and and
meanwhile you would have read
some about 10 examples that have
been given.
All of them are representing the
classification.
So now let's see the
nomenclature right
classification prediction.
All our predictive tasks, but
when you are predicting a
categorical label, we call this
as classification.
So.
So what are the examples?
So here what is the class labels
will buy or will not buy right?
So similarly, you can think of
many classes, so classes may not
be too always so.
So in this case you can see that
the classes are distinction
Merit, Pass, fail so he M.
BF so there are four classes so
so the classes can be any
number, but they are all
categorical variables and when
we are predicting that
categorical label then we call
it classification.
What about prediction?
Prediction is when we are
predicting a continuous valued
function, so it can be like
this.
Say, let's say we are.
We are checking out on the
apartments that are available in
certain locality and you learned
the data that the 1000 square
foot department is costing some
latency arbitrarily.
Let's put 50,00,000 and 1200
square foot is costing.
Costing 65,00,000 and you intend
to buy an apartment?
You got a.
You looked at a new APT 1100
square foot and let me also put
something 900 square foot
apartment is costing some
43,00,000 and now you found an
apartment which has got a square
foot of 11150 square foot and
you want to know what is the
price that you should be paying
so.
So this is representing a
prediction.
So this is also a predictive
task.
But then here you are predicting
a numerical value.
So the classification is an
example of supervised ML.
And there are many unsupervised
ML as well, so they include
clustering association.
The Sacco.
I hope it is clear so far.
I'm just checking whether there.
So just one small question.
In the example of square feet
and and the amount, the amount
was continuous valued and
denomination.
The square feet should be
considered discrete or
Yes, Sir.
continuous.
So I think there is nothing new
like these squidge purpose of
the switch is that you just
learn continuous learning.
So don't keep it for the last
minute.
So that is it, right?
So so there will be there, maybe
even questions on today's
session.
Why not?
Some something right?
OK, I hope I hope that is ES.
Last.
Am I hearing something new?
No.
OK, OK.
Yeah.
So can you go to the last slide?
Somebody is speaking.
I do not know whether.
Yeah.
Can you go to the last slide?
Oh, Mr Arindam.
OK, OK, alright.
So it looks like my mic, I put
it on mute.
OK.
Is this the slide or the one
before?
Yes, yes.
This one or before.
Yeah, this one, this one.
This one.
OK, OK.
Sure.
Please look at it and we are
also going into couple of
references.
One is the Gartner.
So because they this is the
broad classification of machine
learning is supervised and
unsupervised.
But there are many authors who
also include semi supervised.
Many authors include semi
supervised.
You not supervised learning fast
point.
You mentioned the class labels
have training data is unknown.
Can you give an example means?
OK, so you are you want an
example for supervised machine
learning, right?
Unsupervised.
Unsupervised machine learning is
suppose that you got many
customers.
Ohh yeah for your company and
you want to group them for some
reason so that you will be able
to assign suitable level
relationship manager so that is
a unsupervised.
So you want to just group them?
OK.
There is no really.
OK, forget about the purpose
because you want to group them
so that it is easy to manage for
you.
Based on attributes of the
customer, nothing else.
Does that help?
OK.
So that is in fact the very most
popular application of
unsupervised machine learning.
So customer has many attributes
and based on that your group.
So said insult.
And we will see, yes, some
something.
OK, so that in supervised
learning in supervised learning,
whatever data we are taking,
whatever attributes we are
Umm.
Hmm. Yes.
taking.
OK, so we know the output of
that.
What's the resultant is that?
That is correct.
So in supervised machine
learning, what we are saying is
No.
that suppose that we have we are
doing it for medical diagnosis.
So based on the symptoms, the
doctor knows that this person
has copied or not.
They have identified 10 symptoms
and they put the 10 symptoms and
based on that the they have
diagnosed the person has COVID
or not.
Now they train the machine based
on this.
They have observed 10,000 people
and they found that out of them
500 have coded COVID and 9500
don't have kovid and now they
give to the machine saying that.
Look at these ten symptoms and
look at my diagnosis and based
on that in the future you give
the only the symptoms, then the
machine will tell the diagnosis.
A mystery.
Are we clear?
Yes, Sir.
OK, alright.
OK.
OK, let let us go into this.
There is nothing really.
I just wanted to give you
examples where from the the this
is a Gartner is an agency that
you may have heard of.
So in this article they define
the examples of supervised,
unsupervised and semi
supervised.
So supervised, they're talking
about some examples which are
pretty much similar to the
examples that we talked about.
OK.
And unsupervised they are giving
the examples OK how to group
various things, so again be only
based on the data, nothing else.
You don't have any class label,
you're only grouping based on
data and then you can also have
something known as a
reinforcement learning.
Reinforcement learning is where
you are trying to teach a
machine what are the good
things.
For example, you want to teach a
car how to do a self driving, so
there is a machine in the car
which is actually giving
instructions for the steering
and acceleration and braking.
So the machine is doing
controlling them, not the human
driver.
So in that case, the way you
train the car is by doing the
reinforcement learning where you
keep on if the car goes very
close to another car, then you
give a negative points when the
car skips on the lanes without
giving any warning.
Then you give negative points
and if the car goes at it steady
speed, you give positive points
and by doing that you are able
to train the car to do the
self-driving.
Similarly, you can do the
several types of training, for
example robo training or
training to play some game, and
these are the places where there
is no.
What you do is that you keep
giving the points based on the
steps that they take, and once
they observe what what actions
will get them, what type of
points, because they can be many
actions.
For example, playing chess,
there can be thousands of moves
that the that they that the
machine can take.
But by learning that some move
is going to get them positive
points, some move is negative
points in that particular
environment, they're going to
learn how to play the chess.
OK, so this is the.
This is the Gartner's example
and let me also quickly go to
somebody.
Some expert has put uh uh, this
is, I think uh taken from the uh
the X.
Ah, this is a picture posted by
someone to indicate that not
three types.
There are four types of machine
learning.
That is true.
There are authors, there is a
there is.
There are authors who are
generally say that there are
four, but some authors, for
example in our T1 and T4.
Most probably they don't talk
about four types.
They still stick with mostly
about two types, but they may
have taken the example of third
type.
So.
So the point is, don't worry if
the very common ones are
supervised and unsupervised semi
supervised comes in between.
Reinforcement is with respect to
not using the data, but
penalties and rewards.
OK, so now let us proceed little
further.
So how does classification work?
So classification is way you you
do a 2 steps.
First step is that you build a
model.
How do you build a model?
You have an algorithm.
You have data data which is all
preprocessed and quality checked
so that you give that data.
Both of them are given two
machine.
And what does a machine output a
model?
In model can take many shapes.
The model can be as good as
simply an equation or model can
be a rule or model, can be a
graph like a decision tree.
So there are various types of
models that the machine can
build, so all of them have the
purpose that they can help you
in predicting for unseen tuples.
What is the class labels?
I hope I don't need to.
Read the rest.
I I think that my explanation
covers all that I wanted to
point out, so model usage is
that you have a test tuple.
Then you have a model.
And then output is prediction
predict the label.
So the label in case of a we are
analyzing.
Uh, let us say the customers who
are likely to buy our fancy
gadget.
Then the labels can be either
will buy our product or will not
buy the product.
So if we if we are doing it for
a medical domain to help assist
the doctor in making a
diagnosis, then the person has
disease or does not have the
disease and similarly there can
be for example use student with
the performance is going to be
good or not good and similarly
is the weather going to be sunny
or rainy.
So in all these cases we are we
have many attributes and we have
and then we know the labels
based on our historical data and
then we use that and then we
provide them to the machine with
a good algorithm.
So that machine will learn from
the data and create a model.
OK, so this is the illustration
of what we discussed in the
previous class.
So sorry, previous slide.
This is the training data.
So this has been preprocessed
and validated so that we know
the class labels are accurate.
We remove the noise outliers and
missing data and all types of
problems that may exist in the
data we cleaned it up, and then
we did this training data and we
gave them to the machine.
So this is the machine.
So what happened is we are
giving that data and then the
algorithm and then machine is
going to run the algorithm with
the on with the data and is
going to create a model and then
I don't.
once we.
We take the don't we check the
accuracy of the models?
Mr Shamshad, can you repeat the
question?
And on which check the accuracy
of the models of whatever
Yes, yes, you are jumping.
details.
You're jumping.
So so you are probably talking
about what I should tell
OK, I'm sorry.
afterwards, right?
So I yeah, we'll come to that.
We'll come to that.
Obviously first thing is that
you have to construct the model
right, then only there is a
question of accuracy.
Focus.
Great.
OK, so there are many
classification techniques.
So our intent today is to
discuss.
Discuss the decision tree, but
there are many methods.
For example, today there is a.
This is a become a very popular
approach, so we will not have an
opportunity to cover this in
this course, but this will be
covered in the machine learning
and future courses.
Hopefully in future courses I'm
not sure machine learning
include only in deep learning
whatever, but then neural
networks is becoming popular.
For example, the solutions such
as uh, ohh.
Such as what we have is a chart,
Gupta.
Or uh, Gemini.
These are all products of.
That you real networks, they
need a powerful neural networks
in order to conclude because
they generally represent these
can take parameters that run
into that run into billions of
parameters.
So they can take solve very
complex problems.
Presently we have a a neural
networks with I think trillion
parameters.
I'm not sure whether we have it,
but 100 billion parameters.
I understand there are neural
networks that depend on so many
parameters to do this, and then
this is probability based.
And rule based is actually very
close cousin of Decision Tree.
So we will, we will hopefully
we'll see that then support
vector machine is is a way of of
differentiating differentiating
in hyperspace.
So what we do is that we create
a hyperplane because when when
it is A2 dimensional plane so we
align can separate saying that
well.
No.
Ohh so we can say that this is
class one and and the seeds
Class 2.
So we can say that one line is
separating out the elements of
class one.
This is in two dimensional space
which is very simple to
visualize, but then what happens
is that we know that many times
for problems we may have to run
with 100 dimensions or 100
attributes.
So in 100 dimensional space what
you have is a hyperplane that
separates out after significant
transformation of the data you
create that new space 100
dimensional space and then you
find the hyperspace that is
going to distinguish the objects
of multiple classes.
So as a matter of fact, this
here I have taken again in a
very simple example of two
classes, but it can be multiple
classes.
So in that case, if it is
multiple classes then you need
to think in terms of.
And so you can have multiple
planes.
So, so so that way, uh, you are
able to make the predictions.
OK.
So with respect to
classification, there is another
concept that we need to learn is
that the classifier can take an
approach which is either laggy
audit classifier, can be eager.
So what does a lady classifier
do?
So it you give it an algorithm
and you give it the training
data.
What it does is that it keeps
both of them.
It does nothing until it test
data comes up.
The moment test data comes up,
it starts running.
It uses 3 parameters, so in fact
the lazy classifier you just
three parameters test tuple.
Then training data.
And then algorithm.
At the same time, and then the
machine will do a label.
It is going to make a
prediction, so this is it.
Waits until the test tuple comes
so that is.
It doesn't take any spend any
time in training, but then the
lazy classifiers are known to
you, known to have better
performance with respect to the
accuracy because the the test
they wait till the test tuple
comes, then they start looking
at the training tuples which
have a close association with
the test tuples and so it uses a
better hypothesis space.
It doesn't use the entire
training space so so that way
what?
Uh, so so that so this is like a
we already know that customer
which are the customers who
bought the gadget.
So we know their profile various
attributes.
So what we do is that when a new
test data comes in, we what we
do is that instead of building
the model, we start comparing
with the entire training set to
see which are the most relevant
ones for assessing the new test
tuple for whom we need to
evaluate whether the person is
going to buy our gadget or not.
So they buy it, gets a better
hypothesis space.
But then what is the problem?
It takes a lot more time in
making the prediction.
So can I ask a quick question?
Yes, yes.
Uh, she here in lazy
classification, which we are
mentioning.
So like if the test data is less
so and so.
Sorry if the training data set
is large and the test data is
Yes, umm.
more then will will this
algorithm be applicable there?
See, it is applicable
everywhere, so nothing like.
So if you are saying that
training data is low so that
itself means that you are having
you, you you first have because
the moment you mentioned low,
you are saying expressing some
level of a lack of confidence
with the data.
Am I right, Mr Ketan?
Yeah, yeah.
Yes, Sir.
That is, that is because that is
because we we talked about
Where like can be a scenario.
examples saying that why
somebody cannot make credit card
prediction because they do not
have sufficient data or relevant
data or or are the kind of
diversity that you require for
the data.
So possibly you you are
represent.
Finally I went out.
Yes.
Uh, Mr Ketan.
So.
So the point is, yes, you can
certainly use but you but then
you are going to take call
because for example if your
company has to invest 50 crores
in new plank hoping that this
gadget will sell well.
So obviously you want to be a
little more careful, right?
Is it not?
Are you sure? Yeah.
OK.
So are we In Sync so the IT is
nothing stopping you saying that
you can use only this method or
that method, but obviously you
Yeah, yeah.
have to do more diligence with
the data with the when you need
to take a bigger decisions.
But you are when you are playing
it in your own on machine.
So you can try out various
things.
Focus.
Said one question regarding the
regarding bigger, the lazy
Yeah, another question, right.
approach, isn't it beating the?
That you need to come closer to
the machine.
Yeah, it closer to your laptop.
Your voice is coming low.
But that can you hear me now
said well.
Yes, yes, I can hear you.
But it is better if you come
closer.
Yeah, like and speak a little
louder.
Right, right.
So regarding the lazy approach,
isn't it beating the purpose?
Yes.
Yeah.
Because and that we are doing
building up a model with with
the test data already in mind.
So it is not really a new data
that the model is.
No, no, Mr Mr Santosh, let me
clarify.
We are testing against.
You have not built really a
model.
OK, so So what?
What you did is that you kept
both of them.
You have an algorithm to be
used.
That algorithm is for example,
you identify the nearest
neighbor and based on that you
will proceed.
So that can maybe an approach,
so you won't say that you
already have a pre built model.
Mr Santosh Arvind In Sync.
And but in no.
So I mean still little unclear
because what I was thinking was
that OK, the machine is trying
to build a model and this model
Yes.
the the performance of this
model will depend upon how well
it process the unseen data,
right.
See.
That is general purpose of the
classification, so that is what
the classifier is.
But then what?
The lazy classifier does is that
it is going to.
It is not going to build a
general model, so when you give
a test tuple, it is going to do
something, some mental solution,
which is, you may say modeling
which is saying that, OK, if
these two people have the same
age then they are likely to be
doing the same thing.
But then it is not going to
create a model that represents
the entire training data.
It uses only a hypothesis space,
which is the most relevant for
the test.
Tubes.
Are we?
Is that does that help?
And OK, I take that point for
now.
Maybe it will get clarified as
you go for WhatsApp.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Yeah, see the IT is actually we
won't spend much more time on
that.
The lazy classifiers?
The lazy classifiers do not do
much task until they see the
data, but but the the advantage
is that they do entire work only
after seeing the test tuple, so
they are not looking to create a
generic model that applies to
whole world.
They will build a simple model
that applies only to the test
tuple and they solve the problem
and forget the model began
because next test to you comes,
they are going to rework again
everything again.
So to do that.
So we so we call something as a
model when generally for example
decision tree or even neural
networks neural networks because
training a neural network can
take even months because
depending on that type of data,
for example training a large
language model is something
which can take very long time
for them, even with the most
powerful machine.
And so so in such cases, it is
clearly they're not lazy because
if they say that every time you
ask a question, it is going to
build the model, then it is not
going to work.
So can you give a real life
example?
So we have 3 drink everything.
They have to train everything
and then give it so that the
response is deadly fast.
I mean, it is like lightning
fast.
OK, Miss Surabhi, please ask the
question.
Yeah.
Can you give a real life example
that any scenario? Ohh.
Cookie.
OK, so for example, let us take
the same customer data, OK, so
the customer data, what we have
is that we have all the people
who are buying the gadget and
now now what we are saying is
that there are there are cases
for example the there are
examples all over the place in.
Let me draw it in two
dimensional space.
Me.
I'm going to put positive and
negative, OK, positive for.
OK.
And let me put some negative
examples.
This is A2 dimensional data I'm
talking about that OK and now
what I will do is that I will
not bother to build a model on
this.
Suppose I get a new tuple which
I'm going to put it in blue
color.
So I'm I got sunk tuple which is
somewhere here.
So what I will do is instead of
instead of looking at entire
data, I'm going to check what is
the, what is the nearby tuples
nearby tuples are this this this
so I will take these three only
and start building a model
saying that.
OK, so now what can I conclude?
Based on this, Missouri is that
fine.
This attribute can be
inconvenienced and all kinds of
OK, it means.
things, so don't don't. Umm.
It means it.
It means we are labeling here
with these attributes, right?
That whatever the three you have
sown, is it the same or I'm
Yes.
So based on that we we are
labeling, yes, we are labeling
going at?
based on the whatever are the
most relevant part of the data.
So this is A2 dimensional.
Simple, very simplified example,
but in 10 dimensional space also
still we'll do the similar.
OK.
Thank you.
OK, So what we will proceed is
that so here are some examples
of lazy learners.
So very popular one is a K
nearest neighbor and similarly
it can be weights.
So instead of taking all the
neighbors with equal weight, you
can use the some weightage and
then do a based on the
weightage.
You can do the regression and
that can be one and then you can
also do a symbolic
representation and this is a AI
technique where you do a
reasoning based by representing
the entire knowledge in symbolic
way and start putting the
conclusions based on that.
So that again you can do based
on the data that that you have
got the test sample and the the
knowledge that is available from
the already in the data.
So all of them are representing
the the approaches, which is you
go based on the instance not
based on the entire data set.
OK.
So that is that is about the
lazy classifiers.
Now let us look at a decision
tree.
So for the decision tree, this
is a eager classifier.
OK, this is a eager classifier.
So let us explain the problem.
This problem is taken from that
T1's book.
I think the he he seems to us
slightly changed the problem but
then it is good enough.
It is from the so so the way it
works is that suppose that we
have the tax authorities, So
what is the purpose of the tax
authorities?
So they have to make sure that
all citizens play pay tax, so
that is the that is the
performance criteria.
So so it is not an easy job
because we have 101.5 billion
people and the tax authorities
need to collect the alright,
make sure that everybody who has
got a taxable income, it's
paying the tax.
So now the question is that it
is possible that they receive so
many millions 100 million tax
returns or even more than that
every year.
So now the question is that how
do they know that the tax the
tax return is accurate?
So it is possible that they can
do a they can do auditing.
So auditing not an easy job
because it requires a lot of
effort.
For example, the persons KYC is
date or other information is
there.
So they need to go and check all
the transactions that have
happened.
For example, they need to go to
all the bank accounts that the
taxpayer has to check whether
what the person is representing
as the income and what the bank
account shows is seeing and
added to that they may have to
look at many other things like
transactions and high value
transactions.
Credit cards then assets and it
is not an easy job.
And so you know that they do the
IT rights really on very rich
people.
It is not even feasible for them
to check somebody's salary is
9,00,000 or and then that person
reports an 8.5 lakhs.
Rather, they would not do a
write.
Rather, they would like to
somehow decide somehow, find a
way to get the income.
Alright, that is a reasonable.
I mean the appropriate tags from
that person.
So now the point is the problem
is like this.
So they get they.
They will not have a million
staff members, so because to
raid and ought to do a thorough
audit on each individual, where
essentially they need to go dig
through so much of data about
each individual.
So what is the what are the
properties and what are the
wealth and what are the family
members and what is the family
members, wealth and all that
that they need to collect?
And then what are the sources
for each one of them?
So they can't do it.
So what they what they do is
that they so now so they they
have do not have the ability to
audit every tax return that way
fine.
So they need to intelligently
pick the tax returns that need
to be audited.
So what can be the basis?
Because the tax authorities have
been working for 100 years, so
they have already seen millions
and possibly billion tax
returns.
And it is possible that millions
of them have been audited, and
they also know the results of
audit.
So what they can do is that they
have entire data.
So what is the data of the
taxpayer and what is the result
of the tax audit?
So based on that, what they can
do is that they can take the new
tax returns that they receive,
they run them through, run them
through the model and then they
identify what are the tax
returns, which are potentially
there is an underpayment or we
call this class as a cheat.
Cheat is that the person has
under reported the income so
paid less tax than the person
should be paying to the
government.
So now now this is acting as a
training data and then we have
taken only toy set up for data
so that income tax return may
have 100 indicators but we are
taking some simple 3 indicators
and based on that to be have
also the class labels we have
only the income test authorities
may have million records but we
have taken a test to sample of
10 records and then we are
seeing that can we build a
decision tree that will help
them in predicting for a new tax
return should they audit or they
need not.
I hope the problem and the
approach both are clear.
So now, given this training
data, so we already know the
class label, so we can build
this decision trees.
How to build it?
We'll come to that short while
we'll come a little later.
How to build the tree and then
after that one of you even
wanted to know how to measure
the accuracy that will come
after we do all of that.
OK, so now let us see.
Somehow we built the tree, so
now we can see that this tree is
good.
Well, representing the training
data well.
For example, let us take the 5th
tuple.
Refund is no refund is no and
then marital status is D so
diverse, so it is on the left
tuple so refund is no.
So let us trace the trace the
5th tuple, so it is going this
path, then it is going this path
and then after the 5th 5th
people 95K so it is going this
path.
So we see that it is, yes.
So the person is under reporting
the income, so this is the
person has not paid the full
tax.
So similarly, we can take uh the
9th one so refund is new.
Again, let me use another color.
This is for the 9th tuple.
Refund is no.
Then marital status is married
and then the class label is new.
So this is the class label so we
can see that this tree you can
you can take your room time
later and you can see that this
tree truly represents the
training data.
But the problem is that we can
build another tree that also
represents the training data
faithfully.
So this is a different tree, but
this also represents the
training data faithfully.
And so now of course, we so
essentially we are complicating
the problem saying that how do
we pick the correct tree so that
we are going to see a little
later, how do we pick the right
tree when multiple trees are
possible and then we are saying
that once the tree is there once
the tree is done then we have
the test tuple.
We have the test data right, so
test data is refund is equal to
noon.
So test data we are going to
trace then status is married.
So we know that it should be no.
So this is this is the same
picture that we had seen little
longer.
So this is all the decision tree
is supposed to be doing.
So take the data, do the
induction of the tree, and then
apply them.
So now the question that we will
be interested in when we build a
classifier.
So when we build a classifier,
we want the accuracy to be high.
We want this to be high and then
we want the speed to be good so
that it is going to give the
response hopefully in real time
then we want it to be robust.
So it is.
It is robustness as a mini many
points we can see, but then data
may not be.
Me.
Have issues.
So.
So The thing is that you can
never be sure that with the the
data, because it is impossible
for you to go to the point of
the source of the data and
verify it so many times you deal
with the data which runs into
hundred thousands or millions of
records.
So you cannot think of going to
the source to verify each one,
so you can have a healthy doubt
about the data saying that it is
possible that some attributes.
Maybe may not be accurate.
For example, sometimes the
people simply collect the data
from the walkers in the shopping
malls, so you can know that the
people who are collecting the
data.
There is no way even it right at
the time of the collection to be
sure that whether the data is
right or wrong or anything.
So at most they can verify few
things like what is the.
At most I I I don't know what
they can verify whether the
person is young or old.
Maybe I even that I don't know.
So the point is you you may have
the data may have issues, but in
spite of that the model should
work with.
So now really the question that
you will ask is that if the data
has issues, how can the model
work well?
Maybe somebody wants to give a
try.
The data may have issues, but
does the can the model work
well?
We can put some dummy data.
Ah, no.
No, no, no.
Dummy data is actually actually
you are imagining many things
because the dummy data is
representing something of your
imagination. Right?
So.
So the point is that.
So let us do one thing.
Let us be clear about one thing,
one step back.
Suppose that the data is pure
garbage.
Then we can be sure that garbage
in, garbage out, so the model
will also be a garbage.
So there is no doubt about that.
But then suppose that the data
has problems.
Suppose that that some some
elements are missing and it is
possible that some elements are
inaccurate and some elements
there is a noisy instrumentation
that is used.
So the error there can be 10%
variation in what you are
observing.
So in spite of all that, you may
be able to build a good model,
even though some data is
suspicious.
So that is what is we want our
model to be capable.
So even though some small part
of the data will have the
Is there?
problem, it should not be big
distorted because of the small
part of the data.
Missouri, please speak.
Yeah.
So is it related with something
like that we can do that?
Me nor is standard deviation
something.
We can do like this to.
No, no. See me.
See me surbhi standard deviation
applies to only when you have
one attribute.
When you build a classifier, you
are saying that you have large
number of attributes and you
want to predict a class label.
So, so standard deviation may
not be appropriate, but what we
are saying is that in the data,
for example for, let us let us
look go back to the let us go
back to the problem that we
talked about sometime back.
So so now we are saying that the
people with the I, I hope you
remember this.
So I'm just writing that, so the
income.
And the vehicle.
So I'm again creating a simple
data set so that it is clear.
Suppose that income in a key
thousands of rupees, so somebody
has an income of 20 and the
person is riding motorcycle 25
riding a car 30 riding a
motorcycle, 35 riding a
motorcycle, 45 riding a car, 50
riding a motorcycle, 70 writing
a car and 65 riding a car.
So now the point is that this
data has some problems because
we see it is possible.
So we do not know really.
The point is that we cannot go
to the source and verify
everything.
It is possible that there may be
more factors.
There may be more factors, which
is which our data is not able to
capture because of which some
records are not as expected.
But if we provide for some
tolerance, then we can say that
this can be greater than 40
implies that the person will
have car and less than 40
implies the person will have
motorcycle.
So now what we are saying is
that it should have the ability
to withstand.
So now you can say that there
are only 8 tuples, so you may
say 2 tuples are already
creating problems, so 24% no.
But then I had to write the
problem to police here, but the
data you will get hopefully will
be thousands or 10s of thousands
or even millions.
So so having few tuples problem
tuples should not deviate or
distort the model and rest.
I hope you understand the
scalability is that it should be
able to work with large datasets
interpretability.
In fact, this is referred as by
people as explainable AI.
So what we are saying is that we
should be able to understand,
for example, given this model
given this model, uh, you will
be able to interpret saying that
car is an expensive vehicle and
motorcycle is relatively less
expensive and somebody has to
have a car they need to budget
more money out of their pocket
every month or and so for
motorcycles the budget has can
be lower.
So you can make an
interpretation saying that.
OK, so I got a model that seems
to be going well with my own
intuition.
So this is again very very
simple example, but then but
then with the complex examples.
So you don't do it in 5 minutes,
you take months and possibly
months to do that and
interpretation.
Also, people will be thinking
over it for days and months and
years, months before they make a
decision with a conviction.
So I hope probably are In Sync.
Uh, so do we consider these as
parameters whenever we get to
problem statement to get the
result like which classifier
model best fits the problem
statement?
Ah, no, no.
Best classifier model is is not
considered as a parameter.
Uh, But then several of the
classifiers the required that
you learn some parameters.
So for example, in neural
network, i.e.
Was telling that sometimes you
may have to learn large number
of parameters before the neural
network can help you.
Similarly, when we are talking
about things like, let's say a
logistic regression that we
didn't talk or support vector
machine that we talked about.
So there will be parameters that
you need to learn before before
you can duck parameters
represent the model, not
anything else.
So is that good?
OK.
Uh, like, sorry, Sir.
Just to just trying to
understand like the problem
statement which she, Kate and we
try to figure out like what
would be the best fit to solve
that problem like to choose
correct classifier model to get
to a solution sure.
So can we consider those
parameters in this slide as the
ratings for the classification
model?
Ohk.
OK. OK, OK.
OK.
So you are saying that the speed
and accuracy and robustness, can
you consider them?
Yes, yes, you can consider them
evaluating which model to go,
Yeah.
because it is generally said
that the neural networks, in
spite of taking long time to
train, they can withstand the
noise very well.
So that is what is talked about
neural networks.
And so that is true.
So that type of things that you
can consider, but the
interpretability of neural
networks is terrible.
So people generally cannot
explain why it works and why it
does not work, but some of the
simpler models like rules and
rules where people can very
easily explain what is it that
they learn from that data.
So, so that is true.
So you can you can consider them
as some kind of indicators on
what you should go with because
parameters are generally we
consider it as like the equation
has a parameter.
So, for example, suppose that
you are drawing a line.
You are drawing a line which is
W1X1 plus W2X2 plus.
Yeah.
Ohh W3X3 is equal to some EM so
then you say W1W 2W3 these are
representing the parameters X1,
X, 2X3 are representing
attributes so many times the
models that we learn will
require these parameters to be
learned from the data.
So that is why I said I was
hesitant to say parameters, but
then these are the attributes or
the OR the characteristics of
the class various classifier
approaches.
So you can consider.
Alright, so now now let us look
at uh, how does how do we know
Browser The The other one doubt
in the previous slide speed.
whether yes.
I just wanted to understand once
and very much, sorry.
Speed is something like this.
See that you are writing an
algorithm and you're giving it a
data and and I hope you are
learning now.
Data structures and algorithms
you may have learned something
called a time complexity, so
there are some algorithms which
Yes.
take which take exponential time
complexity when given a data.
So they are.
You cannot be sure that so with
the increase in data, whether
they will even reach a
conclusion, miss Mr South of is
that good?
Yes, yes, yes, that's correct,
yeah.
So so that is that is what we
are saying when we talk about
the speed.
So you will not even be able to
build a model in sometimes if
the algorithm and the data set
are of that type.
So but again, you all have
another speed, which is that you
want to predict the label.
So you give a test tuple and
then you predict the label.
So if you go for a lazy
classifier, it is going to take
a lot of time to predict the
label.
But many times the neural
networks you take month to train
it to learn billion parameters,
but after that you give you a a
question or you give a test
tuple.
It will give you the response in
a flash.
Thank you, Sir.
Now let's look at.
This is again A2 class problem.
OK, two dimensional 2 class
problem.
OK, 2D data.
And we have two classes.
What are they?
One is blue and other is red.
So now we can see that when we
look at this data, So what we
can see is that there is clearly
a pattern.
There is clearly a pattern so so
the pattern is that when when
this is. This is.
This is the blue is triangles,
so blue is represented by these
two areas, right, and and then
this is representing the red.
So now now the problem is that
there are many.
So what you notice is that in
this case we are requiring
really a transformation of the
data in order to get the
conclusion.
So we cannot do it comfortably
with X1 and X2.
We want to do it with X1 and X2.
We will have a lot of trouble,
but with X one squared and X2
squared, we are more comfortable
because this is the data.
This is actually a very
synthetic data set that is
created only for the sake of
explaining the problem.
So now the problem is that
suppose we want to create a
decision tree and then we want
to solve this problem where we
don't do the data transformation
but we take X1 and X2.
So what is going to happen is
that we need to create a
decision tree with the large
number of nodes, because there
is a large number of data
points.
So to help them.
So for example, you may require
one node to explain this one
node to explain this and one so
you know many nodes to explain
various well can various values
for X1 and X2.
So what will happen is that you
can get because and there are
many border points, so many
border points are going to go
wrong.
So in such case what happens is
that you need to create a very
complex decision tree and when
you create a very complex
decision tree with the training
set, the error rate can drop.
But you get a test set, then
once you create a very complex
decision tree, then the error
may drop up to certain points.
For example, up to this point,
error is dropping for both test
and training, but beyond this
point the test data error is
increasing.
So that is that is just to just
to help you pick up what we
discussed in the previous class.
So so this is when you have a
large number of.
Data points.
So.
So the point is, this is
something we talked about when
the dimensionality.
So actually we talked about
dimensionality.
It is in.
In this case, dimensionality is
only two, but then
characterization is a little
problem.
So what we are saying is that we
need to do a feature
engineering.
So in this case we need to do a
data transformation.
So without data transformation
this is going to result in a
loop performance.
So without data transformation,
we only focus on building the
decision tree, so more complex
decision tree means that there
is a more errors with the
generalization errors.
So that is we want it to predict
for something which is not seen.
So there will be more errors.
This is a referred as a
phenomenon is referred as a
overfitting, so that is saying
we are trying to depend too much
on the decision tree or the
model we are trying to depend
too much on the model because of
which because of which beyond
certain point the error rate is
improving the rather than
reducing.
So this is a complex this is
actually you need to think in
terms of.
This example is simple.
What we are saying is that there
are many possibilities of errors
at many points, so we the more
the complex decision tree we
build it is it is going to give
more errors in when a new point
comes in because the decision
tree tends to be a linear, a
linear decision tree can only
differentiate based on set and
value less than this or greater
than this and so on.
So this is possibly a concept of
we'll keep it.
I hope you appreciate it.
Otherwise, we'll come back to
this again, OK.
And and then another aspect is
with respect to handling the
noisy points.
So we can see that the this.
So for example, when let me draw
with a different color print
color.
So this seems to be a.
This seems to be a reasonable
boundary.
But to be wanted to fit with the
entire training data and one of
the elements seem to be noise
point and you have no basis to
validate.
Verify whether it is noise or
not, but then.
But then here suppose that it is
a noise point.
Clearly it is.
We are distorting that model by
considering these lines which
are which are again, we are
distorting the space for the
classes saying that the blue
class is going having a complex
space like this and red class
has its complex complex
boundary.
Accordingly so.
So this is again representing a
problem that if we depend too
much on the data, OK.
So.
So now what we do is that let us
take a few minutes break.
We will start looking at how to
create a decision tree.
So this is the explanation of
what is a decision tree and how
to build a decision tree be we
will come back after after Ohh 3
minute break.
OK, let's get restarted.
So, so now we see that decision
trees, uh, we have already seen.
How does it look?
So let's go with one step
further.
So we will look at a classic
decision tree algorithm which is
referred as hunts algorithm.
So it works like this.
So it starts with the training
data set and take the training
data set and start doing the
partitioning.
So partitioning so that we are
going to get partition training
data so that we get purer
subsets.
So let me put it this way.
Partition.
Training data.
So that.
We get.
Pewter subsets.
So what are the purest subsets?
Suppose that I somehow did a
partitioning at this point.
Up to this point, how I did it,
I'm not.
So essentially we have to do it
on set and attributes.
So now we see that this is pure.
This is all the tuples in this
above the green line or having
the same class and the below
this so it is impure because the
sum tuples have the class Y and
some tuples have class N so we
have to have some basis to keep
dividing the training data so
that we the purity of the
training, the subset is
increasing more and more until
we reach at some point so that
everything is pure or or at that
point we decide that we will
should stop because we don't
want a decision tree to be
extremely complex.
So so this is the point.
So we what do we do?
We keep partitioning, so in this
case there is no need to
partition, but we need to
partition this further.
This needs to be partitioned
further.
OK, so now let us let us
proceed.
So let us see with an example.
So then you will be able to
understand.
Suppose that I have initially
initially.
What do I have?
So there is 10 tuples, 77 yens
and three wise.
So at the most basic level, I
say that this training data, if
I have to simplest conclusion,
saying that most of the people
do not cheat.
OK.
But then we are not satisfied
because this is a has only a 30%
accuracy when out of the 10
tuples 3 or Y.
So maybe we don't want to go.
We want to go one step.
So what do we do?
We proceed be used one of the
attributes refund, so we say
refund is equal to yes.
So in refund is equal to yes,
how many tuples I have 123
tuples, so there are three
tuples.
All of them have a class label.
No.
So so I can I can in fact
finalize saying that if refund
is equal to yes, the person is
never underreporting.
So.
So this is something I can draw
conclusions from this data.
So when refund is equal to yes
in the tax filing.
So I can conclude so this is a
dark square around this.
So saying that I'm drawing the
conclusion and I don't need to
proceed further.
Now when the refund is equal to
no, there are seven tuples.
Bear the refund is equal to no,
but then out of them three are
yeses and four or no.
So I have majority of the don't
cheat no, no.
But in spite of that, this is an
impure node.
So I want to proceed with
further splits.
So I come further.
So I see that I want to use next
attribute marital status.
So now I consider among the
people for whom the refund is
equal to no, I divide the
marital status in multiple ways.
I can I have three values?
Yes, M&D.
So I can always think in terms
of the various possible
combinations.
So now again, it is a question
of somebody's domain knowledge
to decide.
So I can say that I can define
like there's three parts.
Yes, M&B or I can define
this as A2 parts where yes and
MRD together or D's together I
can have another path where?
Yes.
And D are together in the M is
together so there can be
multiple options with respect to
what you can do.
OK, so so the point is you can
also have something like E MD on
one side and this is something
but then it is really your
intuition and your domain
knowledge that decides which is
possibly the best split.
And now what I will do, let me I
have to.
It said here in this example.
Uh, at very first step you are
focused where refund is no.
Hmm.
Yes, refund is equal to yes or
no.
Yeah, that is the first
attribute we considered, yes.
OK.
And after taking no you you
carry forward for that.
Yes, that is right we because
with the when the refund is
equal to yes, we have seen that
what we got is a pure node, all
the three tuples they are of the
same class.
So we take it that OK, we got
some level of.
Uh, the confidence that OK with
this, we can keep it as one of
our learning and I proceed with
when refund is equal to no, I
want to learn further.
OK.
Sir, is it like evaluating?
Uh, it is that the question or
something else?
OK.
And Mr Santosh, what is the
question?
No, no.
I was asking is it like
evaluating them?
We do for null hypothesis.
I don't call it null hypothesis,
we use it the only in this in
that case.
But in this case we are
evaluating for the class labels
purity of the class labels.
How to evaluate?
We'll come to that, but now we
can see through the example we
are clearly seeing that we can
go further with one path and in
the other part you don't need to
go further.
OK.
Thank you, Sir.
Alright, so now now let us let
us go step by step.
So.
So now what we know is that in
this case, let me write with
this.
So in this case this is 3 N, so
in this case 3Y and 4N and then
we go one step further and now
we have decided that we divide
this in marital status into two
groups.
One is M and other is yes D and
then again this is an arbitrary
decision.
So let us at this point it is an
arbitrary decision.
We can see.
Then we can see when married.
So now let us consider the
refund is equal to no and
marital status is married.
So how many tuples are there?
One second tuple is like this
and then then six tuple is like
this and then 9th tuple is like
this.
So what we are seeing is that
there are three ants, so this is
a pure.
So this again we can finalize
when refund is equal to no and
marital status is married.
So this and on this side we have
1 N and three wise so the
majority class is cheat but then
still it is not a pure node so
we can proceed one more step we
use that we have one more
attribute taxable income.
We use the taxable income, so
then we are getting the pure
nodes.
So here in this case we are
saying that this is 3 Y and this
is one end.
This is 3 end.
This is 3 end so so we have a
full decision tree.
So where we have 4 leaf nodes
and those leaf nodes are giving
us the class labels and the
internal nodes are directing us
to evaluate for a new tuple.
How to which path to take to
proceed further?
So this is the simple hands
algorithm and now the question
will be that the there are many
considerations.
First thing is that the we are
the we are this is called as a
greedy strategy at every point.
We are trying to.
We are trying to take the next
best step.
We are not considering the next
two next three best steps.
We are only considering the next
best step.
This is called as a greedy
strategy and then what are the
issues?
So we need to address how to
split.
OK, So what is the test
condition and how do we know
that this is the best split and
when to start splitting so these
are all the questions that we
still need to answer.
OK, so now how to specify the
split condition?
So that depends on the
attributes that we have.
The attributes can be nominal,
ordinal or continuous, and then
the types of the split that we
can have, we can have a two way
split or we can have a multiway
split.
So, so now let us look at the
examples.
So this is indicating a multi
base plate.
So we are saying that the car
type can be family or sports car
or a luxury car.
So we are making them in 2-3
splits, so alternately we can
think in terms of only two
splits split into two paths.
So in that case, we need to club
one of the two two of the three
and then keep the other one
separate.
And what happens when we have
ordinal attributes?
So we can think in terms of
ordinary, small, medium, large
for the site.
So we can go with that or we can
do a division small medium on
one side and large on the other
side or medium and large on one
side and small on the other
side.
But what about this?
Does this work?
Do you think this is ever this
is something that we will ever
use?
No.
Yes, unlikely that we will use
it.
Unlikely, but then there may be
some kind of situations that we
can imagine because again the
ordinal is actually depends on
the way you define.
For example, let us take the
railway reservations.
So suppose that the age is we
are considering as ordinal.
We are treating the age groups,
for example child then adult and
senior citizens.
We can treat that as an ordinal
attribute if we think that the
age is the only the size or the
OR the value of the edge count.
So, but then what happens is
that the railways gives
concessions to child and senior
citizens, but railway does not
give concession to the adults.
So so sometimes you may have
some Special Situations where
you think that, yes, ordinal
attribute may have to be split.
But then again, we are going
into the pure domain space, so
it is the domain that demands
that you take the approach, but
it is as as you pointed out, it
is more likely that we will go
with these approaches.
It is more likely.
But this can be a specific
domain based.
OK, so now let us look at the
continuous attributes.
Continuous attributes.
We are saying the income, which
is a value which can take from
anywhere from let's say 10,000
to 10 billion.
So now, now we are talking about
how to handle the income.
So income is we can take
multiple approaches.
One is that we can do a
discretization.
We have already studied how can
we do a discretization and then
the IT becomes a categorical
attribute.
So now we are dividing the all
the income into instead of
numbers.
We are calling this as a low
income, middle income and high
income.
Or it can be more than three.
We can go for five groups, six
groups, so just we call it ultra
High and upper middle class or
below poverty and we can start
creating many, many groups.
So in that case, what we are
doing is we are doing a
discretization, then we can
treat after discretization the
the attribute continuous
attribute like a categorical
attribute.
The problem with that is that
that is static and it static.
One can also work very well for
some many situations, but then
sometimes you may have a
problem.
For example, what will happen?
Suppose that we have an income
tax data.
OK.
We have income tax data and then
we are solving the same problem.
That is, we are we are trying to
help Indian income tax
department but what the Indian
income Tax department gave you
gave us is the 100 years of X
data.
Ohh so they have been collecting
taxes for so long and then they
said that OK, you start building
a model for us.
So what will be the problem if
we take the income and we use a
static labels like low, high and
middle?
Just imagine what can be the
problem.
But the difference was being
three years.
Inflation first of all.
And inflation.
Uh, can you repeat?
What?
What is it you said, Mr Rajesh?
And the definition of low,
medium, high is continuously
changing.
Absolutely.
Right, right.
That is correct.
Absolutely right.
That is the that is the point I
was hoping to hear from one of
you.
So so now the question is that
you obviously have to think
about it, right?
So for example, your company may
give you a data with 20 years
because the many companies are
there in business for a long
time and then they say that, OK,
this is the values of what
happened with the various
customers or various products
and all that.
So now you need to consider many
factors before you say that.
OK.
Can I discretize or do I have to
think more?
So one approach can be somehow
do a categorical, convert it
into categorical or or or do go
for binning right?
So so we are doing a equal
interval type of mining.
So this can be one approach.
This can be one approach equal
interval binning or equal
frequency one we can go for that
or we can go for percentiles or
or clustering wheels.
Study that later.
How can we use that clustering?
Then we can use a binary one.
So less than or greater than so.
So the point is we have to think
we have to think and we have to
think about the domain.
We have to think about the data.
Then we can decide what to do
with the categorical, because
the problem with the problem
with the continuous attributes
is that you may have a large
number of values, so so the for
example in your company there
may be 10,000 employees, but the
salary of each 10,000 employee
is different.
So it is possible that you have
10,000 numbers.
So in that case it is not easy
for you to think in terms, but
maybe in government they can
identify the grades or scales
because which is typical with
the public sector or government.
But in private you may not have
that, so you may have each
individual may have some salary
which they have computed through
some basis.
So so now the point is that you
need to think of intelligent
ways in which you can handle
such a data to build a the
model.
So here is a pictorial for the
same.
So you can think in terms of
binary split or you can think in
terms of a multiway split.
Good.
Can you just explain once again,
I'm not very much clear about
discretization.
Discretization you don't
understand discretization.
What is that you don't
understand?
Yes, Sir.
I am not very much of a table
with this term.
So suppose that there are people
with varying incomes.
Is that clear?
There are people with diverse
incomes.
So now you can say that somebody
below 20,000 income you say is
Yeah.
a low low lower level income and
20,000 to 1,00,000 you say
middle level income and above
1,00,000 you say high income but
does that is that clear.
So the three are actually
category categories are discrete
values, right?
Yes or no.
Yes.
So we are doing categorization
there.
Yeah, that is what is not
discretization leads to
categorization right?
Because you created when you
create discrete intervals, each
discrete intervals becomes.
Can be called as a category or
we without even category.
Also, you can keep it saying
that you want to treat zero to
20 as a.
You don't give a low.
You give the label as under 20
and then 20 to 40.
You don't call it middle, but
you say 20 to 40.
Which is the label can be
anything.
But I said low middle higher
because so that you the IT is
easy to see what is the purpose
but the label can be anything.
OK, OK.
So now now we are have got 20
records.
OK, so 20 records.
20 training tuples.
OK.
And then 10 records of Class 0
and 10 records of class one and
we have 3 attributes to choose
to split the data.
And now I have given you the
three splits that are possible.
Think about them and tell me
which one you are liking.
I hope the question is clear.
You have to tell me which split
are you liking?
Among the three.
The cartoon one.
A.
That.
Yeah, got type.
Will you be little lighter?
Yeah.
OK, when the car type 1.
Cartoon.
The car type?
You're liking that is Mr Rajesh.
No.
OK, so anybody?
I I would go for the first one
to know whether somebody's.
OK, Mr Anirudh, guys preferring
the first one, Mr Rajesh is
saying the second one which is
the car type. OK.
So anybody have is a they you
can give anything you can agree
with either of them or you can
still go for a different one.
So you you can speak.
OK, Mr Amri, Amitesh is also
going for the second one.
OK.
So second one, we have got more
people going for it.
No.
OK.
First one is just binary.
Yeah, second.
OK, miss.
Yes or no.
So so it's more clear giving
more clear direction.
OK, so so the point is what Mr
Remick is saying is that the
first one is a simple to
interpret, so that is that is
something.
OK.
But but then many people are
going for the second one.
So somebody who is going for the
second one, can you explain in
your own words why do you want
to go for 2nd?
Uh, because Sir, if we go for
the second type itself is saying
that somebody's owning car, but
that information is already
there and.
OK.
Yes.
No, no.
So we have second gives.
Owning the thought is yes.
I think second because based on
the yeah, please go ahead.
So, so on.
So it depends.
It depends what's the what
outcome we need, what kind of
model we want to make on base.
OK.
OK, Mr.
Lee, Mr be.
Just hold.
Let us give others chance,
because I I I I understood
It so the second one gives more
data in a sense like if you have
whatever you're trying to but.
car like 6-4 persons are there
who have car and they are like
this model gives more data in a
sense like which type of car
they have and the ones who
doesn't have anything like that
information we already have that
it that doesn't have like they
don't have car so it covers all
the.
Ohk.
I I will come.
OK. OK.
No, no, no.
OK.
Yeah, Mr Amitesh, you want to go
further?
Yeah, I mean it, it covers more
scenarios like we have more data
with this one.
OK, three scenarios, but then
what is what is give?
What is pushing you to go for
second one?
Forget about the attribute name.
Still early.
So let let me let me give you
some some.
So.
Come understand why that I
understand.
Let me give you some hint.
It's no call this as an
attribute one call this as an
attribute, 2 call this as an
attribute.
Three, forget about the rest,
OK?
This attribute you can keep this
OK?
You still call it as attribute
3, so now now you think about
which one seems to be a better.
A better split?
Forget about the name of the
class name of the attribute and
Uh, they can.
also the call it as a value one
value 2.
I went for it because it has
more pure it has more pure,
Second, have a categorization
categorization.
pure, almost pure subjects.
Ohh.
OK, OK.
Who is who is this?
Yes.
Who is this?
Mr Rajesh, who said this pure.
Yeah.
Ah, I said that because it has
more pure subsets.
Basically the 2nd, that's why I.
Yeah.
OK, OK.
So what is the?
What is the purity that you are
observing?
So there is one set where you
know, like all it's 80 split
basically right, which means
it's you have upset already.
You absolutely right.
Like that is that is very good,
right?
Right.
That is very good observation,
saying that when one value it
takes, it is clearly doing a
complete classification of the
tuples based on only that value.
So it is pure.
Even others are nearly pure,
though they are not pure,
they're not completely pure.
Others are nearly pure.
Do other people are able to see
this?
So this is the.
Yes, Sir.
This is the kind of intuition
you need to get.
This other people are able to
see that I'm.
I'm just waiting for answers
from the other.
Yes, Sir.
Yeah.
So seeing that the this is
giving you a improvement in
We agree, we agree.
purity, significant improvement
because at this point at this
point it is completely impure,
because 1010 means that it is
completely confused.
You it will not help you with
the drawing any conclusion but
the moment you use these values
of this attribute you could see
that you got something
absolutely pure and these two
are nearly pure.
So that helps you in proceeding
further with greater confidence
that, yes, you are going in the
right direction.
OK, this is this has got too
many splits so this may not be a
good attribute and in fact you
can see that the student ID is
the name of the attribute
whenever you have got too many
splits then you have to be
concerned that if then you start
thinking whether is it really a
very indicative attribute for
the class or not.
OK, so now now we we have to
think about.
So the greedy approach that we
talked about for building the
classifier decision tree is
straight away saying that this
is bad.
It is saying that this is bad.
This is good anytime you get
this type of node nearly pure
and highly impure.
So this call you call it as a
impurity, we're we're all the
classes are equally present and
one class is almost of one
class.
Then you call it as a high
purity.
So what we need is that we need
a major to indicate that this is
bad and this is good.
So we have 3 majors for the node
impurity.
So the three majors are Gini
index entropy and
misclassification error.
So now let us see when we build
the decision tree, how do we go
about?
The machine will go about
computing at each step to see am
I going in right direction.
So what do we do with the
impurity measure?
So we measure the impurity.
Suppose that this is the data
and then the split will divide
it into D1 and D2.
So we are going to measure the
impurity at this level D0I zero
and then we measure the impurity
at this level and then we are
going to see we are combining.
I-1 and I2 and we see how much
is it an improvement over IC?
OK, so that is the broad
concept.
So now let us see so so an
example.
Suppose that this is the data
that represents 2 classes C0C1
and then we are going to have a
impurity of M0 at this level and
then use attribute A to split.
We are going to get impurities
for both the nodes M1 and M2
with the B we are getting 2
impurities M3 and M4.
So we are going to combine M1
and M2 and M12 and M3M4 and M3
four and then we are going to
check which is a better
improvement.
So we will see in an example.
So then you will understand the
point is that our intent is to
check for impurity at each step
each level and then and then for
each attribute we try with the
at the same level.
We try with various available
attributes and see whichever is
giving an improvement in purity
that we are going to pick.
So now let us look for the
formula for Gini index.
Gini index is for any tuple when
there are multiple classes, so
there are multiple classes class
J at node T So what is the
probability of class J at node
T?
So we are going to to consider
for all the classes the
probabilities and then we are
doing summation.
OK, for all the classes.
So suppose that there are there
is a node with six tuples.
6 tuples in a note.
And suppose that class one is
zero, Class 2 is 6.
So we compute this 1 -, 0 ^2, -,
1, ^2, so that is equal to 0.
So in this case class one has
one tuple, Class 2 has five
tuples, so we compute.
We get this when we have both
the classes are equal to pull we
compute.
We are getting .5 so here is a
computation.
This is the computation that we
have shown in the previous
slide.
So when it is 3 and three class
one and Class 2 then it is most
impure.
OK, So what we'll be getting is
1 by 1, three by 6 square.
So this is giving an indication
of the impurity level.
So more the Jenny index, more
impure, the node is the smaller
the Gini index, more pure than
ones.
So that is the understanding
that we can compute.
That is the conclusion we can do
and then machine needs some
number crunching before it can
do anything.
So this can help the machine to
do the number crunching and
proceed with the construction of
that.
So what do we do when we have
multiple nodes when we split?
So what we do is that when
suppose that we have a D0 and
then we divide this into D1 and
then we divide this into D2.
So what we do is that at this
point we are saying that D1 size
of the node, so and then Ginny
for the node divided by.
The entire data set, so it is D1
plus D2.
Bless D2 that is the size of the
D2 divided by the same thing.
So this is indicating the Gini
index of of these two nodes
together.
After we do the split.
So let's look at the example.
So that may help you.
Suppose that there is.
At this point there are 12
tuples.
And the Gini value is 0.5
because there are six tuples of
class one and six tuples of
Class 2.
So we split on this attribute
and node N one got 5 tuples of
class one and two tuples of
Class 2.
Node N 2 got one tuple of class
one and four tuples of Class 2.
So Ginnie for node one is 1 -, 5
by 7, ^2 -, 2 by 7 squared.
So you can see so this is for
the node one.
This is for the node 2.
And we combine them using the
weighted summation because the
node one got 7 tuples, node two
got 5 tuples.
So this is the weighted
summation.
So what is the gain?
The Guineas.
.5 -, .37.
So this is a gain of .13.
So if you have more attributes
so the machine can compute for
each attribute, what is the
gain?
And then choose the attribute
that gives the greatest gain.
So now let us look at some
examples.
Some more examples, just to see
what is how it is working.
So we are doing here.
Previously, we had a Jenny of
C1C2 or four and six, right.
So this is four and six.
OK.
So previously we had set in
Jeannie value G0.
So now after doing a split we
are getting this here this here
and this year and this has the
greatest gain.
But then but then we will also
look later on saying that this
is giving you more gain, but it
is creating a more complex tree.
Because the tree at this point
has three paths and these these
are providing less complex
trees.
So we'll come to that little
later.
So that will be another
consideration.
We'll see.
So between these two this is
better right?
Between these two, this is
better.
OK, so now let us see what do we
do with continuous act review.
I hope people are clear so far.
Sir uh, is it like uh algorithm
internally calculates Gini index
OK.
for each and every attributes
and come with a conclusion
Yes, yes, yes, yes, that is
correct that is.
without without we doing it
manually or the those things,
Yeah.
Yeah, obviously that is what is
the machine learning is.
right?
So the we are looking at one of
the machine learning algorithms,
so the machine learning
algorithm is that it is going to
So maybe maybe.
create a decision tree given a
data and training data.
So we are seeing how to write
the algorithm.
OK.
So, OK, so Sir, maybe.
Uh in machine may come up with
some conclusion which may not be
a.
Means which may not be concluded
by normal human being.
So in that case, we will, we'll
discard that model.
No, no, no, no.
Just, no, no.
Look at this, Mr Vinay, the
machine is doing what you said.
So obviously you have to change
your algorithm if you think that
the results of the algorithm are
not good.
So it is like any other
algorithm.
So machine learning is actually
we give a name because uh, OK,
Got it.
the name is established, so we
can't question it, but the
algorithm is still written by
somebody either.
So maybe in Python there are
many libraries that people had
already built, so you you will
feel that things are happening
without your doing.
But somebody has programmed,
somebody has programmed it and
Yeah, yes, yes.
you are using that.
But if you think that you are
not satisfied, for example your
you have a very specific
requirements and you're not
happy with the library, you can
write this nothing stopping.
So you can write the algorithms
are not that complex, so given
some one week time, you can
certainly write a good new
algorithm.
Thanks Sir.
OK, so now let us see what to do
with a continuous attribute
continuous attribute.
We are seeing that we can take
multiple choices, no.
So we can do a splitting.
We can do a multi splitting or
we we can do a two way splitting
and if we it is a two way
splitting which is the point
where you should do the split.
OK, So what we can do is this or
what the machine can do is this.
So essentially we have to
program the machine to do this.
So what the machine, what we can
do is that we can constantly
keep increasing the the split
point.
Keep trying.
So here.
What?
What is?
What is happening is that we are
trying the split .1 is at 55 OK
one is 657280879297 hundred 1000
twenty 272 and 2:30.
So we found all the split
points.
We tried all of them and we see
that the best split is occurring
when we choose 97.
So we are getting a lowest Gini
value when the split is at 97.
So on this data.
How did we choose this split
point?
Or I missed that?
So we are trying, we are just
trying so that so look at this
Just randomly.
97 we took you see that six
tuples are below 97 and four
tuples are above 97 and out of
the six tuples that are below 97
this is 97 right?
6 tuples below 97 or but this
this, this, this and this.
So am I missing something 123456
so out of this we are seeing
that 6 tuples and they are
breaking into three wise and
three N's and then other four
are breaking into simply four
ends and three Y.
Sorry zero wise.
So when you compute the genie
for this and this together, and
we'll combine this, So what you
are getting is that you are
getting a lowest value here.
In all other cases, you're not
getting that good.
When?
So what are we computing out of
this genie index?
Or means if we say like here the
Gini index is .3, what are we
concluding here?
So what we are saying is that if
you want to use the taxable
income as the attribute, so
taxable income as the attribute,
so you split saying that less
than 97 on one side and greater
than 97 on the other, and then
you are going to get a better
Umm.
tree or a better quality
results.
If you choose the income, but
you can also choose the other
attributes and you do the same.
So here you are saying that the
gain you are getting is .3.
Sorry, the Gini is impurity left
in the data is .3 but but the
other others also you can try
and if you if the impurity is
further reduced.
Sorry, the purity is further
enhanced or the impurity is
further reduced.
Then you can go for the other
attributes, but the with this
attribute.
What we are saying is that it is
not so easy, so we needed to try
many combinations and
permutations.
Permutations.
Before we could identify 97 but
for categorical attributes, we
could see that it is relatively
easy.
In this case, we are finding
that this is the best right if
we want to go for two way split.
If we are ready for multiway
split, this is the best.
So uh, this gin index makes the
model more accurate and more
confident than.
Yes, because finally the point
is that how do you explain it to
the machine they there is no way
you can explain it to the
machine except by the help of
numbers, right?
So if you are saying that there
is 2 attributes, marital status
Yes.
and refund, how will you explain
it to the machine?
You have to break it down into
numbers.
Then the machine is more more
inclined to do the job right?
Or the machine is becomes
capable of doing the job.
There is nothing like
inclination for emission, but
the machine becomes capable of
doing this.
Is there are we supposed to
calculate these?
Yep.
Uh Gini index, and then do some
calculations are based upon that
numerical be given as a
question.
Why not?
If required, you can do that
right?
Because we have shown all the
calculations.
So what is the?
So it is so.
Uh, so I just one thing, so
lower like lower the Guinea
index, then lower the impurity.
The purer the node, the purer
the node.
This also concludes.
Yes.
That means where we split it
that the correct correct.
And we want beautiful.
OK, Sir.
We split it by the correct.
Yeah.
What should I say?
Yes, Mr Rumic actually correct.
Maybe a difficult point.
So let me go back to the basics
of what we, no, no, no, no.
Or maybe better, I would say.
Let me let me I think I I never
possibly explain to you.
Have I explained to you the
concept of the all the data
science or the machine learning
we are going for?
What is known as a P AC?
So which is probably.
Approximately.
Correct answer.
So so you cannot say that you
got it absolutely right.
So for example, we have
discussed about how many, many
experts sit together and do all
the statistics and data science
and finally end up getting the
election results wrong.
So the point is that you you can
only try based on the
probability and approximation
some value because the you are
never because data science is
you're dealing with a large
volumes of data, so you cannot
go to the individual tuples and
start fixing them.
So you were effort is to be more
to higher probability and higher
accuracy rather than saying that
I'm right I have I clarified it
little better.
Yes, yes.
Yeah.
So because this is considered as
a the science of probability and
approximations.
So now let us look at a
alternate splitting criteria.
So, so now let me let me remove
these things.
Yes.
So Alton, this is an alternate
tool, 2 Gini index.
This is called entropy, so
entropy works like this.
So you consider the probability
of each class and multiply it by
multiplied by.
Something is missed out here.
Log of to the base of two.
So so you we take the
probability and then multiply it
by the log of the base log to
the base of two, the probability
and then the overall value.
We are going to put a negative
sign.
Why do we put the negative sign?
Because log of the numbers
greater than one is negative, so
the probability is always less
than one, so you always get
negative.
So by adding a minus we are
making sure that the entropy
turns out to be positive and
entropy is also a major of
impurity.
The lower the entropy, the
better the nodes.
So like the Gini index, this is
also indicating the impurity
level.
So what can be the range of
values in this case it can be
the maximum value can be log NC
which is the number of classes
and the minimum value is 0.
So now let us again compute with
some examples.
So you will be able to relate.
So suppose that we take this
example.
OK.
So C1 is 0 and C2 is 6.
So what are we saying?
So the probability of Class 1
multiplied by log to the base 2.
The probability of class one
bless probability of Class 2
multiplied by log to the base
two of probability of class two.
OK, so this is class one is 0,
so whatever you multiply this
with, this comes out as zero
though log log 20 is actually is
considered Infinity.
But then when you compute this
as, it tends to 0, this comes
out as zero.
Then probability of Class 2 is
1, right?
This is equal to 1 C two is
probability of Class 2 is 1.
So log to the base two of
probability of Class 2 each
zero.
So log two of one is 0 so that
way the entropy for both of them
put together will come out at 0.
So this indicates that the
impurity levels are zero, so
there is no impurity in the
node.
So once we go for others, so we
compute in the same way.
So PC1 is 1 by 6 and log of base
two of 1 by 6 and then this is
PC-2.
Is this so?
How do you compute this?
So maybe I will help you with
the calculator.
So, so now let us do the
calculation.
So no so.
It said it said here I have one
question that whatever the class
Yes.
we are taking C1C2 do can we
have that overlapping data
Hmm.
overlapping tuples?
Or no.
No.
You are saying that something in
both class one and Class 2? Is
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
it?
No, no, no.
When training data, you expect
the training data to have that
type.
That much of clarity, so it is
with the test data that you
don't know, but in the training
data itself.
If you don't know the class,
then really that cannot help
you, right?
OK, OK.
For each of the training to pull
your expected to.
So now let us look at how to
compute for the so so the this
is like this.
So run by 6 multiplied by log 21
by 6, so 1 by 6 is .166 right
and then .166.
How do we compute the log of
base two and hoping that some of
MU may not know?
That is why I'm treating because
in the calculator there is only
log, so this will give you the
log with the base of 10.
You need to divide this by log
of to the base of two.
That will give you the log with
the base of two, so this minus
2.59 is log 2 of 1 by 6.
So.
So let me let me put this here
minus 2.59 right.
So I'm talking about minus 2.59
and similarly we can do for the.
Uh.
The five by six.
5 by 6 is .833 right?
So we need to do it with the
same way 833 and then we take
the log of that and then divide
it by the two log.
So that will be minus .26.
OK, so this is.
Minus .26, right.
So now we compute this so it is
1 by 6 of 2.59.
So whole minus is taken out
because this is minus and the
whole the entropy sign itself as
minus plus 5 by 6 of .26.
Thanks.
So you compute this.
This comes to .43 and this comes
to.
This comes to about .22.
This is equal to 0.65, so
whenever so essentially all I'm
saying is that the log 2P is
equal to log of be divided by
log of two.
So so this is a because many of
the calculators will not have
direct computation for log of
the base two.
So you need to use this formula
to compute.
And also just one doubt minus
2.59.
So the yes.
Sorry, we're minus 2.59 and the
last previous slide.
Yes.
That calculus and I just wanted
to check it out.
Ohh, who is speaking?
I'm not.
Sort of sort of here.
Yeah.
Mr Saurav?
Yes, yes.
OK, so you want to know that the
what is that you want to know
So this.
you want to.
Yeah, yeah.
You want me to go to the
calculator?
No, no, that I have done the
calculation.
I just wanted to listen.
Yeah.
OK, so it is log of the base two
log with the base two you 21 by
6, one by six is approximately
.167, right?
That is what I directly used and
then you multiply it by 1 by 6.
Yeah. So.
So this is the formula.
Yeah.
Can see the formula right on the
screen.
Yeah, Rao, Sir.
I just wanted to I my doubt is
that minus sign was there that
you know that you know it it has
disappeared.
Yeah, because that is see in the
formula in the formula, entropy
I'm just trying.
has an overall minus.
You can see that entropy formula
that minus and this man is
OK.
Ah, that's the reason Aug got
it, yes.
getting cancelled.
Yeah.
Yeah, I explained to you in the
earlier saying that because the
probabilities all the
probabilities are less than one,
so the logarithm of them are
always minus.
So that is why we keep a
additional minus so that the
entropy is always positive.
Got it, got it.
Got it.
Thank you, Rosa.
Thank you.
OK, so now we can have another
criteria which is the
classification error.
So it works like this.
So what you do is that the you
compute the classification error
as one minus maximum of the
probability of all the classes
together for that tool.
So it is.
It is a simpler calculation.
So what we are doing is so we
have two probabilities here,
right?
We have two probabilities, 1
needs 0.
Maximum of zero and one we take
and we subtract it from the one.
So we are getting a 0.
So this is again the
classification error.
We call this as a classification
error which is coming here.
So in this case, what is this
one minus Max of 1 by 6 and five
by six?
5 by 6 is maximum, so you
subtract this and you're getting
value of 1 by 6 and in this case
you're getting a value of 2 by
6, which is 1 by three.
So this can be another way in
which the machine can compute
the impurity level in the node.
Again, it is saying that the
impurity level here is 0.
In this case it is 1 by 6 and in
this case it is 1 by.
And also here we are saying
error.
Does it mean that we are not
getting complete purity?
That's why we are saying error.
Yes, that is right.
Now see in this node we are
saying that the class is 2/6
tuples are there in this node.
I'm looking at the third bottom
node.
OK, bottom node 6 tuples are
there 1/2, class one has got 2
tuples and Class 2 has got 4
tuples.
Obviously it is not pure, right?
Yes, yes.
So he say that impurity level is
1 by 3.
So why are we using term
computing error?
Use.
So that's what I'm confused
little bit.
OK, OK, this is computing error
is actually this is a
classification error.
OK.
So we call this.
This is the classification
error, so maybe maybe here
computing.
In this case I should put here
classification error, but
sometimes people put the people
use a simple term saying that,
OK. Yeah.
OK, we are computing the error
when I go to that node instead
of going for Ginny and a
entropy, they got a technical
So.
terms, but the classification
error you may refer as simply as
error.
So, so, so out of these 301 by
6, one by three.
Sorry, we are the router, so
zero will be the zero will be
Umm. Best, right?
there.
Yeah, you.
Best, right?
You always like to get that type
of node, yes.
Yeah, yes.
List list.
Yeah. OK.
So the splitting criteria is
going to be like this.
Suppose for a two class problem,
whenever you have a probability
of one class is .1, the other is
.9.
So this will be the value and
when it is .5 point 5, this is
the value.
So entropy will be one and
Jeannie and misclassification
will be .5.
And when it is .8, this is the
type of values that you get.
So this is just to understand
that they are all helping you in
improving it.
So they are constantly improving
up to .5 or so essentially
whenever the class.
So when you have two classes .1
and 2.9 and the other one is .3
and .7, all three of the majors
are saying that this is better
than this better.
Right.
So that is that is what all of
them are saying.
And so now we look at, yes, yes,
yes, good.
The that one question there,
Sir, this is enabled.
So so now we have three, I would
say methodologies in order to
come up with the best possible
combinations, right?
Thank you.
Or this splitting criteria.
Yes, yes, yes.
Uh, and we saw the two class
problem, but how should we
Yes.
decide which approach is better?
Which algorithm is better here?
Yeah.
I see nobody has really because
most of the people, the experts
say that they give more or less
at least entropy and Gini index
work more or less well.
Classification error is not used
in many times and the algorithms
that you use, they may have some
default saying that either
entropy or Gini index, but they
permit you to choose the the
heuristic that you want to use
for for doing this split.
So they allow you to specify
which is the split criteria that
OK.
you want to use.
So really all of them give more
or less similar quality decision
trees.
OK.
Alright, Sir.
Thank you.
Then we will go for one more
concept and this concept is
expanding beyond entropy.
OK, so this is this is
essentially going beyond entropy
gain ratio.
So it works like this.
Suppose that we have got a a.
The entropy that we are
calculating, we have the formula
and then we we are looking at
the gain and then we are looking
at the game.
So now what happens is that.
Suppose let me go back to the
some a screen that I have shown
you long ago, some half an hour
back.
Right.
Suppose that you look at this.
I wanted you to think about this
right, so now you can see that
when you consider only entropy,
this will have after the split.
This will have.
This will have entropy which is
0.
This has an entropy which is
small.
This will have entropy, which is
large after split right?
So it is so easy between first
one and second one to say that
entropy of small is better than
entropy of large.
But then what you will do with
this attribute which is giving
you an entropy of 0.
So this is able to do this by
doing a large number of splits.
So for example, there is an
attribute which is.
You have a data set of services
1000 and there is one attribute
which is taking 500 values.
So using that attribute you may
get very small entropy, or you
may get very high gain.
So to prevent that attribute
dominating, we use a new major
which is derived from entropy,
which is called as a green
ratio.
So what we do is that suppose
that we have a data set and we
are computing the entropy.
We are computing the entropy of
all the paths.
Then we are also considering, so
this is the entropy calculation.
So we have 3 attributes, income
and then whether student or not.
What is a credit rating and then
based on that, we can get the
what is the gain that you are
getting then what you do is that
because income and possibly
there are more values for these
two for the student, there are
only binary split but for credit
rating the split these fade and
excellent it is also binary
split but with the income it is
a split along 3 paths.
So what we do is that the income
is giving a small gain.
Income is giving the this much
gain and the student.
So in this case, yeah.
But then what we want to do is
that we want to normalize this
by this split information, which
is saying that if we are
dividing it into multiple paths,
we consider this formula.
Suppose that we have 16 paths.
So what we do is that 16 paths
dividing.
The data equally.
So the split information will be
minus Sigma of 1 to 16, then 1
by 16 multiplied by log 2 of 1
by 16.
So that will come as that will
come match.
So so this will be equal to 16 *
1 by 16 * 4 because this minus
four because of the minus in the
formula it becomes.
So now what we are saying is
that split information is 4.
So we are saying that when we
are dividing it by 16 paths, we
divide the gain gain by the
split information and then we
use the gain ratio to decide
which is giving us the best gain
among all the attributes.
So if you take the example, you
can try with this example.
You can try with the example at
home.
I'm giving this as a task.
Just try and convince yourself
that gain ratio will eliminate
the third path, even though
third part is giving an entropy
of 0 or maximum gain.
So if you use the gain ratio,
that will say that the second
attribute is better than the 3rd
and 1st attributes.
So you can validate that
yourself and I'm stopping with
the gain ratio.
So is I hope it is understood.
You apply that formula and then
try with the.
Yes.
OK, Mr Rajesh, it's clear.
So so you try that with the same
data set with the three
attributes for each of them, you
compute the gain ratio.
So in this case the student ID
be eliminated because we said
student ID cannot be useful
because it will never provide as
a discriminative information or
even when there are too many
paths, we can easily notice
that, but the gain ratio is
giving us a sophisticated metric
whereby we can see we can
automatically consider the split
paths and the gain in the
entropy and then combine them to
see identify which is the best
attribute to consider.
So are there any questions?
So we I'm we are overrunning so.
Yeah.
So what we can do is this is so
refining the decision tree
model.
So there are there is a little
few more concepts on how what we
can do to refine it further that
uh, we can take in the next
class.
So I'll take now at this point,
if there are any questions on
what we discussed till now, I'm
willing to answer.
Umm yeah.
Yes, Sir.
Can you go on page #28?
So.
Oh, oh, you.
Go to the slide #2028, right.
Yes, yes.
Yes, it just give me one minute.
Yes, this one, right.
Umm, no, after this that is.
OK, this one, this one. Right.
OK, OK. Yes.
Yes, yes.
Here's her uh, when we choose
that car type, why you are
Yes.
telling that that two the 1st
and the 3rd node you are telling
as a nearly pure and the center
one is pure.
Why it is so?
OK, first node, you can see that
both the classes are present,
right?
There are four tuples out of
them.
One tuple is of class zero and
three tuples are class one.
Second one is pure because there
is a nothing of class one.
Everything is of Class 0, so we
call it pure.
If you compute the entropy for
this node, it will come at 0.
Even the Gini index will come at
zero for the third, third tuple,
third node.
We are seeing that these C0 is
only one C one is 7.
So if you compute the entropy or
Gini, it will come as very
small.
Is that clear misery?
Yes.
So here it means that in node
that it in a particular node we
uh whatever data we have, we are
dividing into those two classes
right?
It is it like that or something?
This is the two class problem,
Miss Ruby just just to go.
Two classes?
We are going with the two class
problem.
Yeah, go ahead.
OK.
Go ahead. Yeah.
OK, OK, got it.
Got it, Sir.
So in each node there is two
class and in that class that
whatever tuples are there on
basis of that we are comparing
the node values that which one
node priority yeah OK.
The purity.
No. Purity.
Yeah, right.
No, right.
And then for the and then we
have a mechanism to combine all
of them.
We have seen the mechanism when
we split across multiple paths,
we take the weight is we give a
weightage of this one we get say
weightage of four.
This one gets a weightage of
eight and so.
So suppose that we are using
entropy, so this is this is, let
us say even and E2.
These are the three entropies so
we say that the four by 16 of E
4 by 20 right 20 of E 1 + 8 by
20 of E 2 + 8 by 20 of E 3.
So we say that when you split
using the attribute to our car
type.
So this is the entropy new
entropy that you will have.
OK, OK.
Sir answer another question is
later with Guinea index, but I
think people are waiting for
you.
So first please, I will ask at
last.
OK, so people want to ask more
questions. OK.
Yeah, yeah, go ahead.
So other people have some
question.
So.
Yeah, I have a question.
So when when we are doing a
discretization for the numeric
attribute, right?
So the number of the Genie index
doesn't give us any information
regarding the number of
categories we are going to
split, right?
So in the example we did A2 way
split uh, and then we found the
That is right, great.
genie index for all the possible
like splits that you can do.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
The example is only two way
split.
But suppose that you want to do
a 3 way split to saying that the
income you want to categorize as
low, middle, high, or some way
some number of categories.
So you need to do go by trial
and error because the point is
that we have seen that the
numerical data we have seen that
there are many ways in which you
do the normalization or
essentially we learned about
binning.
So the binning is we can take
multiple approaches for binning
hand.
Each bin may represent something
so.
So the point is, there is really
nothing that you can do.
You have to do a various types
of trial and error in order to
see what is it that you get, but
typically like we are seeing
that the income is middle high
and low.
Similarly, you can have for even
our other products.
For example, you have gadgets.
Let's say it is a mobile phone.
You know that people have
already divided the mobile
phones based on some criteria,
saying that one is high and
mobile phone are there is
something.
Then.
So the point is price is again
the divided, so the numbers they
get divided there is a based on
domain knowledge.
But there is a reset only.
No, no foundation or found
theory to do that.
OK. OK.
Thank you.
So will this lecture be in?
Will this like lecture be in in
a in the quiz?
So my question is that is there
anything in this lecture that
you did not understand?
No, I understood.
OK, then why are you?
So.
You are already ready for the
quiz, yeah.
So.
Sir, how many questions will be
there?
So, Sir, what type of questions
we can expect?
I mean out of these lectures.
All the antiques all are M sick
is all our MCQ and my.
He understood things, but like
we need practice and for that at
least we need one day.
Right, like so many medicals and
concepts.
No, no, no.
Do you?
Don't don't worry.
I mean, don't don't go with that
type.
See the when we set the
questions, they will be
challenging but somewhat
challenging.
Not not saying that it's
something you cannot do, but
then something that we know that
we we have seen.
In fact, we we have experience
with several colleagues of yours
with you were kind of
background.
So you don't have to worry
about.
The how many questions are how
much time?
Those are already set.
I think 20 questions will be
there and you get one hour to
complete.
Five points are there right?
20 question 5.1 hour.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, that is
correct, yes.
So all our multiple choice
questions so.
Yes, right.
Sir, can you explain once that
Guinea index?
Yes.
Yes, Jenny index, what is the
question you have Miss Ruby?
Uh said, actually.
I was just stuck with pure and
impure and I was not that much
focused on Guinea index that I
was trying to understand the
classification that how that
node it is now.
It is clear that how it is.
Yeah.
So that's why I just want to
understand this once again, Sir.
None of the formula of Gini
index right?
What is that you want to you?
Yeah.
Yes, Sir.
I have formula and how we are
putting the value here that I am
OK, so so you want you want to
know how we got .278?
not working with.
Yes, yes, yes, everything's for
this one.
OK, you want to know this.
So The thing is that you you you
understand this is 1 node right?
Yeah.
So what is the probability of
class one?
Yes, yes.
This is equal to 1 by 6 right?
But I probability of Class 2 is
5 by 6.
Uh.
Is that correct?
My 6 and 25 by 6 probability of
Class 2 uh.
OK, for you are talking about
only the second one.
The second node, yeah.
Now you're same thing applies to
any known. Now it's.
Yeah.
OK.
Yeah.
OK. OK, OK.
So you can use the same formula
for everything.
OK.
OK.
Yeah.
Ha ha ha.
OK, so so all we are doing is we
are using this computation to
OK.
OK, OK. Yeah.
compute the G so we got the
probability for these two and
then we are subtracting the
square of that and then we get.
So is there any specific range
for Genie impurity that it
should be range?
The maximum for a two class
problem can be .5, but for
OK.
higher class problem it can go
it minus of 1 by three one by
three.
So it can be higher for higher
class problems.
It can be higher, but for two
class problems, it's the maximum
can be .5 for higher class
problem it can go higher but
never below beyond one because
this is you know you from the
right from the formula you can
say you can never go beyond
that.
Yeah.
It'll be ranging from zero to
0.5, but basically.
You with the two class problem,
but for three class problem it
can go a little higher.
The range can be a little
higher.
For entropy, Sir.
Entropy.
It is the same thing now it is a
0 to one and the for higher
class problem it can be from the
entropy range is.
Let me go to the entropy slide
so that I don't confuse entropy.
Yeah.
OK, so the range will be from
zero to OK 02 log 2 NC when
number of classes is 2 it is 0
to one.
When it is 4, it is from zero to
two.
When it is 8, it is zero through
three.
When with the 8 classes and when
it is something in between,
suppose that if it is 3 classes
so you are going to get log of
base two, it is going to be
about 1.7 or something like
that.
OK.
Thank you.
So this is this is the thing.
You can compute it using the
calculator.
What will be the range?
Yeah.
OK so please upload this
annotated.
PPT.
Ohh this is going to be heavy.
OK, fine.
So The thing is.
Yeah.
OK, I'll I'll do this.
Thank you.
A.
Bye.
Thank you, Sir.
What you see here?
See just I want to understand
like log it is category like if
we are divided into 2 then basis
two if we divide into the three
then it's become three.
That that class actually.
Yeah, you're seeing it correct
class.
OK, OK.
The value of the entropy maximum
possible value of entropy.
That is what we are seeing is
that the question or something
else?
So in this slide, I'm trying to
ask see value of C.
No.
OK.
Which slide the current slide,
right?
The currents like, yeah, yeah.
This slide only, right?
Yeah, yeah.
C is the category, he explained.
My colleagues explained me.
No, no.
C is indicating the number of
classes.
NYC is indicating the number of
classes, so it is a two class
Exactly.
Who?
problem.
Log to the base two is of two is
1, so it is zero to 1 entropy
range.
But when you have 8 classes and
then you have to build a
classifier so the entropy range
can be from zero to three.
OK.
OK, OK, Sir.
Thank you very much Sir.
Yeah.
OK, so to see the annotated OK.
So if there are no more
questions, then we can close
this session alright.
Thank you, Sir.
Happy New year.
Thank you, Sir.
Yeah, I think you need to all of
you, yeah.
Thank you.
Happy New year.
Thank you so.
Happy New year.
Thank you, Sir.
It's a happy New year.
Happy New year.
I've been you here soon.
Seven years old.
Yeah.
Happy news.